avec le directeur général adjoint de
l'ifop on va commencer avec votre
sondage
à marseille un sondage ifop pour la
provence seignosse et sud radio
on va voir ensemble les résultats et
d'abord les résultats de ce premier tour
c'est un sondage marseille global
je le précise alors qu'un marseillan
votre par secteur on verra tout à
l'heure un des secteurs d'ailleurs mais
sur ce sondage marque cei robe global on
va donc voir les résultats frédéric et
c'est martine vassal la candidate des
républicains qui est en tête
oui 24% d'intentions de vote c'est un
score intéressant mais il ya un mais
d'une part de rassemblement national été
traité au niveau très élevé quasiment à
son étiage de 2014 et à un point du
score de marine le pen en 2017 24 22
c'est dans la marge d'erreur est vous le
disiez oriane on est sur un os sur une
élection qui régit pas la loi plm
il ya huit secteurs 24-22 ça veut dire
qu'il ya des secteurs où stéphane ravier
et nettement en tête
deuxièmement on sait très bien que dans
toute élection quel que soit le lieu la
division constituer un danger est
presque mortel et la droite est
fracturée la droite est divisée puisque
martine vassal à face à elle un candidat
divers droite bruno gilles qui obtient
10 % 10 %
il est en situation de se maintenir au
second tour bien sûr une alliance est
possible mais il peut rester des traces
et puis dans ce sondage
ce qui frappe c'est la division de la
gauche la fin de l'ère gaudin aurait pu
donner aux marseillais dans un cadre
dans le contexte d'un mandat dans une
fin de mandat extrêmement difficile avec
ce qui s'est passé rue d'aubagne
notamment l' envie de gauche ce n'est
pas le cas le printemps marseillais
arrive certes en tête mais la gauche est
fracturée entre le printemps marseillais
samia ce n'est gagner quand j'entends
les 10% c'est un score intéressant pour
être ça veut dire qu'elle est sans doute
en tête dans son secteur et 10% pour les
écologistes
on a un paysage marseillais fracturée
mais quand même
avantage pour martine vassal qui doit
jouer entre un équilibre entre
l'héritière du jean claude gaudin mais
également quelqu'un qui va être en
rupture avec lui elle y arrive
elle parvient à rassembler deux tiers de
l'électorat fillon presque deux tiers de
l'électorat jean paul bodin mais elle
est clairement gêné perd sa part cette
dissidence justement voilà pour le
panorama général
on va on va rentrer dans les détails
avec vous frédéric on va commencer par
martine vassal vous disiez 1 celle qui
est en tête dans ce sondage mais elles
payent le prix de la division c'est ce
que vous avez dit bruno gilles et à 10%
le candidat dissident est ce que
clairement vous voyez dans l'électorat
bruno gilles pénalise clairement martine
vassal oui je crois qu'il capte un
électeur fillon sur cinq un petit peu
moins de 17 % d'électeurs jean claude
gaudin la division c'est un danger
mortel
la division c'est quelque chose qui peut
pénaliser la droite dans un contexte
compliqué alors certes la droite a
plutôt la vamp où le vent en poupe à
l'échelle nationale puisque dans la
plupart des villes elle a conservé ses
sortants les municipales c'est
d'élection de la stabilité
on a tendance à reconduire les sortants
la situation est différente dans les
villes le maire ne se représente pas et
surtout jean claude gaudin l'époque jean
claude gaudin est maintenant terminée il
était maire depuis 1995 il était
candidat contre de fer en 1983 c'est
quelqu'un qui à 50 ans de vie politique
marseillaise et c'est clair que la fin
de mandat s'est plutôt mal passée
marseille sur la base de ce sondage je
pense que par secteur ça devrait passer
le rassemblement national peut être plus
haut que ce qui là je répète 24-22 on
est dedans on est dans la marge d'erreur
on sait très bien parlons extrêmement
franchement que souvent le rassemblement
national notamment dans le sud et un
petit peu sous-estimé en 2014
ils avaient été sous-estimés de quelques
points en tout cas sur la base de ce
sondage
stéphane ravier garde à coup sûr ou
presque son secteur il a une chance
d'être bien placé dans un second secteur
parce que la différence aussi par
rapport à 2014 et 2008 c'est que ce qui
était la règle dans les configurations
de second tour c'est-à-dire le duel va
devenir l'exception sur la base de ce
sondage il ya tout simplement cinq
listes en situation de se maintenir au
second tour il faudra 10 % des d
exprimer sa magali à neuf et tangentent
également la barre des 10
et c'est vrai que c'est un sondage ifop
fait pour les républicains
au mois de décembre données martine
vassal seul tour de 30 % à 24 % c'est
plus compliqué pour autant elle est dans
une dynamique et elle fait la course en
tête
contrairement à stéphane ravier qui lui
est peut-être moins dans la dynamique
qui stagne dans les arbres et on va de
stagnation dans
une enquête de mon conférer de société
autour de 20 ou 21 % pour la provence et
des tomates janvier si je me trompe pas
clairement là la thématique de la
rupture
la thématique d'une nouvelle page pour
marseille le nom de ce thalys et
retrouvons marseille après je le répète
une fin dr godard est extrêmement
compliqué hein j'ai des enquêtes de
l'ifop qui montrent que sur les grands
indicateurs marseillette et 10 points en
dessous de la moyenne nationale
une enquête de l'ifop pour la
marseillaise montré que presque un jeune
sur deux souhaitaient si la possibilité
à jeune sur deux marseillais quitter
marseille
voilà on est sur une période très
compliquée où il n'ya pas de sortant
jean claude gaudin ne sont clairement
pas martine vassal peut être vu comme
les comme l'héritière et sa la peña les
salles à dieu comme l'héritière ne
pourra durer intentions de vote sur la
base de ce sondage on verra sur le
secteur du jeu johan bodin plutôt pas ce
qui est compliqué c'est il faut jouer
sur deux leviers l'attachement malgré
tout presque nolte presque nostalgique
des marseillais à la figure 2
jean-claude c'est à dire 50 tandis
politique marseillaise 25 ans maire de
marseille et puis clairement un
mécontentement sur des questions de
propreté sur des questions de sécurité
c'est la question de mots de mobilité
marseille est une ville très très
attendu beaucoup plus que paris est la
mobilité en dehors de la voiture est
extrêmement compliqué jaegli a très
fortement des sujets de récriminations
martine vassal si elle est vue seulement
comme l'héritière des gens heureux d'un
qui va continuer l'oeuvre d'hugo l'un
pourrait être pénalisé pour autant elle
arrive de manière assez délicate à jouer
entre ruptures continuité continuité de
l'oeuvre gaudens losc a le plus plu aux
marseillais
l'attractivité de la ville son
développement économique
et puis quand même une rupture sur la
gestion quotidienne qui très clairement
a laissé à désirer et vous disais une
fin de mandat difficile pour jean claude
gaudin dont on aurait pu aurait pu
bénéficier la gauche mais vous le dit la
gauche à l'édifice
en trois listes et c'est michel ribeiro
là qui capitalise devant les écologistes
oui le printemps marseillais qui donne
une impression d'union de la gauche et
le parti communiste le ps génération
yafei à voir la france a soumises et
finalement je les mets dans le choix si
je puis dire siffler la fin de la récré
la gauche à marseille
la gauche de la région grand sud ex paca
si je puis dire et en difficulté
rappelons qu'elle a disparu du paysage
régional aux élections de 2015
a marseille il y avait eu une tentative
d'union qui a globalement échoué il ya
la liste divers gauche de la sénatrice
samia ghali qui est bien implanté sur
quelques secteurs marseillais notamment
le sien il ya les écologistes ce qui
peut être ce qui peut surprendre dans ce
sondage c'est le poids relativement ténu
des écologistes puisque dans les grandes
villes de france où tenue par la droite
ou la gauche se présente divisée quasi
systématiquement par exemple à nice les
écologistes sont devant le parti
socialiste là avec cette union il ya
plutôt un avantage pour le printemps
marseillais
soyons très prudent sur la validité du
sondage on sait qu'entre ces listes et
peut y avoir de la fluidité
il peut y avoir de la volatilité de
l'hésitation jusqu'au dernier jour entre
un vote écologiste à votre printemps me
marseillais ou un vote c'est magali et
un mot sur la république en martinique
en marche très bien ils vont berlin à 7
% à 7 % dans une ville qui n'était pas
ma cronje les mêmes macron arrêt a
réalisé un score inférieur à sa moyenne
à marseille en 2017 c'est le problème
qu'ont la plupart des prétendants dans
marche c'est à dire que quand on regarde
les déterminants du vote
d'une manière générale dans une grande
ville aux municipales c'est déterminant
repose sur un triptyque bilan programme
au projet incarnation c'est à dire une
personnalité par définition de super
lent n'a pas de bilan puisqu'il n'est
pas sortant le programme le projet c'est
difficile de l'imposer dans cette drôle
de campagne qui a peiné à mobiliser les
électeurs effet coronavirus effet
réforme des retraites etc
et puis l'incarnation ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui est très connue des
marseillais ce problème on le retrouve
dans toutes les villes où la plupart du
temps le score de la liste abékan marche
pas ne soutient pas un maire sortant
comme
à toulouse comme à beauvais ou ailleurs
est souvent de deux fois inférieur voire
trois fois inférieure aux scores
présidentielle des macros clairement
parce que le vote en marche repose sur
un vote d'étiquettes abbott de marque
partisane ce que n'est absolument pas du
scrutin municipal clairement à marseille
comme ailleurs ce sera sans doute très
très compliqué pour aller re aiment
aller on va regarder ensemble les
résultats du second tour un résultat de
votre sondage
même si c'est compliqué en le second
tour encore plus à marseille avec ces
secteurs quelle analyse vous faites de
ces résultats du secondaire je vais être
extrêmement prudent puisque bien sûr
vous le disiez il céder un vote par
secteur y aura huit second tour sans
doute au soir du vote même si des
secteurs peuvent passer au premier tour
je n'en vois pas en 2014 deux secteurs
de jean claude gaudin était passé et
encore de très peu normal le premier
tour et puis quand on pose une question
de premier tour en béton avec qu'il faut
fiducial les habitants en situation de
vote ce dimanche prochain devait se
dérouler le premier tour sur un second
tour il manque par définition une donnée
essentielle la connaissance des
résultats du premier tour
imaginons une poussée plus forte que
prévu du rassemblement national
un écart bruno gilles martin face à plus
fort que prévu tout ça peut changer la
donne là je dirais à plat le second tour
plaqué ou à l'issue du premier tour
donne une victoire pour martine vassal
qu'on imagine en alliance avec bruno
gilles mais la gauche si elle se réunit
pour réussir pu réussir un score élevé
mais on sait réduire lectorat peuvent
suivre aussi bien bruno gilles petit
martine vassal que les éclairer les
électeurs de gauche peuvent se mêler
vous savez il peut y avoir
des traces de la campagne difficile du
premier tour mais le second tour répond
aussi à un impératif pour les électeurs
de droite et ceux de martine vassal et
ceux de bruno gilles sont assez proches
sociologiquement c'est éviter que la
gauche reprenne le contrôle de la ville
à gauche c'est tourner la page de l'ère
gaudin mais il peut y avoir de la
déperdition dans soulageant voit qu'une
petite partie de l'électorat écologiste
choisi martine vassal
on veut que la république en marche se
fracturent complètement et elle choisit
davantage martine vassal que la gauche
qui explique cet avancement assez
maussade on va se focaliser sur un
secteur un secteur numéro quatre à sept
secteurs de jean claude gaudin dont vous
avez parlé 6e et 8e arrondissements de
marseille avec votre sondage paru ce
matin dans la provence et martine vassal
qui est largement en tête
oui alors c'est le secteur historique de
la droite ces deux secteurs de jean
claude gaudin il avait été majorité en 2
en 2014
et la voilà le rapport de force global
change sensiblement martine vassal
arrive nettement en tête 37 % elle fait
le point
elle fait le plein pardon de l'électorat
de droite elle relègue bruno gilles à 31
points versus 14 sur notre sondage ifop
fiducial marseille globale alors c'est
un très bon résultat mais elle n'arrive
pas du fait de la division à l'étiage
jean claude gaudin on voit très bien les
traces on essaie même dans un secteur
acquis à la droite
ce mandat très compliqué ce dernier
mandat très compliqué de jean claude
gaudin la gauche si un choc mais elle
est tendanciellement en recul par
rapport à notre enquête sur mme assez
globale c'est plus équilibré entre le
montre le printemps marseillais et de
goût marseille liste europe écologie et
verts
et puis égaliser égalité et maigre si je
puis dire non ils sont pas égales pour
elle a le rassemblement la sonatt dans
cette terre de droite est nettement en
deçà de son score douanes et ce qui est
bon berland qui est très loin
voilà le même secteur que martine vassal
exact d'avancé si je puis dire son
secteur voilà on voit très bien il fait
mieux que son score global 10% il peut
entre guillemets négocier un ralliement
où il peut se maintenir pour le second
tour on voit très bien même dans son
secteur
la vraie difficulté pour l hérault même
d'exister à marseille